Y el muchacho regresó para la casa de mis padres y les dijo,
¿qué es lo que va a estar pasando con su hija?
No contó nada.
Yo hice mi pregunta.
A mi señora,
me mandaron,
nominaron y me hablaron.
Yo hice una pregunta yo.
¿Cuánto uno en la vida quiere lograr antes de poder lograr?
¿Cuánto uno quiere poder lograr todo?
Esa fue mi declaración.
Contestó, ¿qué puedo lograr?
¿Cómo me contestó?
En ese tiempo, en el año 38.
Y así pasó.
Entonces mi señor era muy religioso.
Se fue para su papá, Rabino,
diciendo a mí,
mi hija, el único que hija mía,
se enamoró.
Y dice que para ella,
usted sabe,
gran comerciante,
tiene moneda,
gran trabajador,
no...
no es tan muy como nosotros te sabemos,
porque tan muy no tiene fin.
No tiene fin, tan muy no tiene fin.
Entonces mi papá contestó.
Papá de mi señor,
tú tienes que ir para el gran sabio de la guerra de Ebre.
Y eran muy creyentes en su señor Rabino.
Cuando él pasó allá,
le puso su cartita de qué se trata,
el Rabino de la guerra de Ebre no contestó nada.
Una palabra no.
Y yo, hermano,
más alto.
Y a mi señor se quedó la boca,
ya no podía hablar más.
Que no conteste nada, más alto.
Entonces la cosa ya está hecha.
Yo estoy llegando del bosque,
le viene, mire,
con mi...
uno que lleva los caballos,
yo estoy sentado atrás,
me hace un señor, mire,
él viene al frente,
se cae el montañado,
y viene,
yo voy a ser contigo
como hizo Rabino conmigo,
más alto.
¿Qué pasó?
Panevá en esto.
Así me dijo mi Rabino,
ya tú eres mi hijo,
ya tú puedes venir a mi casa.
1930, Noel,
8 de junio,
era matrimonio.
¿Cómo yo puedo tener ese matrimonio?
Aquí la gente no cree.
Por la ley judaísmo,
hay siete brujas,
y siete días,
el novio no puede hacer nada.
Cada día, 8 brujas.
Imagínate.
Y a mí me dijeron,
que a mí me mantenían,
de mis negocios,
siete días cerrados, mire.
Que yo no me reventó,
era yo el dueño, mire.
El abuelo de ella me cuidaba, mire,
como si él era un bandido.
Ese, cada día,
había que hacer tres veces comida,
y brujas.
Usted sabe de eso, ¿no?
Usted sabe.
Pasaron siete días,
matrimonio.
Te digo la verdad,
para mí no era luna de miel.
No era.
Y Varsovia tenía un edificio
de doce oficinas,
con 24 empleados.
Exporta a Alemania.
Aquí, murieron alrededor de 300 obreros.
Más de 100 obreros en bosques.
No tenía teléfono.
No tenía teléfono
que podía llamar,
como llaman aquí, mire.
Y todo fue atendido,
mi hermano me ayudaba.
Y todo yo tenía que atender.
Mi trabajo.
¿Y qué sabía de lo que pasaba
en Alemania en ese momento?
Yo sabía todo.
¿Cómo yo sabía todo?
Yo siempre, mire,
yo era, mucho me gustó,
cuando tenía tiempo, leer.
En Polonia, era un periódico
que se llamaba Curio-Warsawski.
Y en este periódico,
Curio-Warsawski dijo así, mire.
Que es, es,
agarran niñitos,
ponen los dedos en piedras
y pegan con piedras en uñas.
Cuando yo dijo,
muy conocidos,
dicen, es propaganda.
No es verdad.
¿Por qué
llegó
situación en Alemania
y y que llegó el poder?
Por mala situación
en Alemania.
Era muy malo.
Él tenía una boca para hablar.
Y libró,
ganó elecciones
y libró,
todo gente de palos libró
y apuso jefes de ellos.
Usted sabe que hay en Talmud,
que hay en Talmud.
Nosotros somos un pueblo para sufrir,
no para gozar.
Todo el tiempo, mire.
¿Dónde quiere pasar la historia?
Inquisición en España.
Inquisición en Italia.
Todos saben.
Y no saben todos,
pero no la vieron.
Yo estuve en Italia
y yo quise saber
cómo mantenían allá los judíos.
Un metro cincuenta de ancho
y un metro de altura,
un kilómetro de largo.
Allá nos dejan entrar.
No hizo que me hayan entrado.
Pagando bastante dólares.
Y yo la vi
de nadie con mis propios ojos.
Y hay un gran aviso
con letra de oro.
Yo la vi eso.
Estamos en treinta y nueve.
Estoy llegando, mire.
Llega un comerciante de dinero
por Corea
y entra a la oficina.
Me dice la jefe de la oficina.
Sr. Rice, un polaco.
Primer de septiembre.
¿Sabe usted que hay una guerra?
¿Cómo es?
No era televisiones.
Viaja por Lasca.
Toda aviación ya está liquidada.
Toda aviación más grande que era
y se va a viajar por Lasca.
Allá vive un hermano mío.
Señorita, ¿cómo es posible?
¿Es el que usted está viendo?
Me quedó
exacto
dos meses
porque yo me casé.
Me puso lleno.
Me puso yeso.
Vengo para casa
y digo yo a mi señora.
Oye, mi amor.
Esto que yo
todo era verdad.
Genes dijeron que no es verdad.
Vamos a llevar todos mis tiros
que se me hicieron para Matamoros.
Vamos a empacar
en un cajón
y vamos a contar con un polaco.
Adam, ¿qué estás haciendo?
Ya me llamaron.
Ya cambiaron mi nombre.
Adam.
Nombre polaco.
Inmediatamente.
No cambiaron ni papeles.
Así.
Mire, yo veo la cosa muy oscura.
Lo veo muy oscuro.
Este era Shonagabah.
¿Cómo es?
Shonagabah.
Hay ocho días sucat.
Y un día hay, se llama...
Usted sabe que es Shonagabah.
Y yo me paro.
Con energía.
Mire, señores.
Agarrar y huir de Polonia.
Yo veo todo.
¿Qué va a pasar?
Ay, tú eres un joven muchachito, joven.